ça fait partie de mes nouvelles passions
le supprime et puis dans sa permanence
du monde voilà alors qu'est ce que tu
fais jamais alors ben je pourrais sur la
course
si je peux dire puisque cette
circonstance j'ai un nouveau titre qui
est arrivé à un tout petit peu plus
d'une semaine et s'intitule pas la gay -
qui réalisé par djimrabaye oscars au
chaud et voilà je pense que je commence
à me mettre rien emprunt bien en rôdant
à la cause des vacances 2018 alors par
ags et moi c'est bizarre apag et moi
alors pas la guerre moi c'est une
nouvelle sonorité pour moi puisque c'est
du zouk
c'est du combat je veux dire c'est du
compas
brouillade donc pour être dans la
tendance mais pas seulement
c'est surtout mon faire danser les gens
et voir regarder tout le monde s'amusait
et se distraire broyeuse mans 2-1 port
d'accompagner seul un porte-monnaie mais
la joie dans la danse et le chant sur
mon interprétation qui m'a plu c'est une
petite histoire un petit peu
tristounette ça mais quand même du
bonheur personnel
écoute c'est souvent ce qu'on pose comme
question alors quoi répondre je dirais
simplement être sincère dans ce qu'on
chante pour que tout le monde puisse se
sentir concerné et et voilà donc oui la
sincérité dans ce que je chante c'est
pour ça que je perdrais le
merveilleusement ce que je fais